i am pissed not really but i recently uh
was on a podcast a few months ago via my
first million podcast uh with sam and
sean great guys and we were talking
about my book 100 offers which you can
get on amazon kindle for 99 cents if you
don't have the dollars for a hardback
and i heard on a later podcast that i
wasn't on that sean was saying yeah i
really love the book um but it's just a
bummer it doesn't apply to e-commerce
and i disagree
and that is why i'm making this video to
break down why the value equation and
the things inside of the 100 million
dollar offers book which pretty much
this this visual right here inc you know
encapsulates or or summarizes the the
vast majority of the pieces in the book
and obviously there's a lot more
examples and stories and there's you
know a lot of five star reviews on
amazon so check it out for 99 cents if
you want but the main point is that
these are variables that create
purchasing decisions that get people to
value something in order to buy it
because they value it in excess of price
tag and the idea here is if we
understand the things that drive value
then we can understand the things that
underpin price which then lead to
profits all right and so in the book i
do give a lot of uh service based
examples uh both b2b and b2c but i
wanted to take this video uh to do
something a little bit different and
talk about how it applies to e-commerce
all right because at the end of the day
people buy stuff because they value them
right and so the application may be
somewhat different but the fundamentals
and the the variables are the same okay
and so quick recap on this dream outcome
is people actually have to want the
thing that you're delivering to them
number one number two is that when they
buy they will buy based on the perceived
likelihood that they're actually going
to get that thing so it's like a lot of
people may want to get rich but they
will buy the one that they think that
has the highest likelihood of actually
them getting there right or a lot of
people might want to look skinny but
they'll work with the physician that has
worked with 10 000 patients rather than
their first patient because they're
perceived likelihood of actually getting
skinny or getting the surgery they want
is higher and in a very real way value
it more time delay is how quickly
something can happen right as between
when i buy and when i get if we can
compress that time horizon or that
timeline the more valuable it is if i
can get you a six pack in 30 days for a
six pack in 30 months which one you
value more of course the 30 days one so
we try and compress the time horizon
along how we deliver our products and
services and then finally effort and
sacrifice are the things that we have to
start doing that we don't want to do or
we have to give up doing that we do want
to do as a result of the purchase and so
in a perfect world we want to deliver
someone the dream outcome and when they
buy it because they have extremely high
likelihood or they're certain that
they're going to achieve that and
they're going to achieve it overnight
with ease right so fast easy
and exactly what they want the way they
want it to be delivered all right so
that's what we have to think about here
now in the book i talk about scarcity
urgency guarantees bonuses and naming
right and so what i want to do is just
apply these and the easiest way to look
at this and and prove out the point that
this 100 applies to ecommerce is to look
at the e-commerce giants all right
specifically let's just look at amazon
and over time they've really nailed down
hitting each and every single one of
these variables that drive value now if
you are an e-commerce person and you're
like why i can't sell on amazon well one
is you can the other is that you can
start thinking about it through amazon
lenses and of course it's taken him 30
years to build this thing right but we
can still think if this is the
theoretical that we need to try and
shoot for this is the ideal scene then
we can start taking steps towards it to
improve the value of our offerings okay
cool now if let's say i wanted to buy a
jacket all right so this is a very
different example than my normal ones
and i have other examples and services
in other videos but this one is just for
physical products so let's say i wanted
to buy a jacket my dream outcome might
be that i look good in this jacket that
could be an outcome it could be that
it's very warm ideally maybe it's both
of those things right and i might even
want a jacket that looks good and that
isn't warm because i just want to wear
it because i think it looks good but i
don't want to get hot right so it
depends on what my dream outcome is
right so you're gonna have different
messaging for different avatars
depending on the on on the product
itself and what problem it solves all
right so let's just use for example that
i just want a fashionable jacket that
looks cool okay that's point one around
what our dream outcome is great now i
may be a buyer who's like but i'm not
that fashionable and i don't really know
how to like pair stuff and make it look
cool all right so what are the ways that
we can increase the perceived likelihood
of achievement of me achieving this cool
look all right well first off is reviews
if i have lots of five star reviews on
my page and i can read them then i'm
more likely to make the purchase because
i see other people made the purchase and
are happy about it right makes sense
that's why reviews amazon pioneered this
and then it became commonplace because
it increased the perceived likelihood of
achievement right what else can we do
and i actually saw this levi's did this
for selling a jean jack which is why i'm
giving the example because it was so
masterful and how they did it what they
did is that i saw this video it was uh
maybe 90 seconds and it had the jean
jacket and it had three different ways
you can wear it and they showed here's
how you pair it with dark stuff here's
how you pair it with light stuff here's
how you pair it with the same looking
jean and blah blah and i was like wow i
did not know how jean jackets work but
now i do and now i know how to wear it
so my perceived likelihood of achieving
the dream outcome of looking cool has
just gone up simply by them making a
video that demonstrated it right these
variables apply to services and
e-commerce just the same
it's just the way that we show someone
how to experience the dream outcome they
desire differ alright in a let's say
it's a i'm teaching a skill i'm going to
show somebody who has the skill showing
them demonstrating the skill and the
results of of having that skill right
that would be increasing the perceived
likelihood but if it's a physical
product then we have to think what's the
outcome they want and then how do we
increase the likelihood that they they
see that and easy ways to demonstrate it
right and to literally demonstrate this
is probably what you're thinking and
here's how it works that's why unboxing
videos and things like that work because
it decreases the risk associated with
making the purchase because they're like
oh that's what's going to happen it
decreases the other side of me swiping
my card what happens after that right
and as much as we can demystify what
happens after they say oh i now can
create expectations and then these this
product will meet the expectations and i
will be happy great now the next one is
time to like amazon has been the pioneer
of prime of two day shipping one day
shipping one hour shipping right and
they continue to try and drive this down
because they know that the faster they
can get people the things they want the
more that they will value and like it
and repeat buying on the platform right
and so this should be a no-brainer this
absolutely applies to e-commerce all
right now the next one and that can also
apply at different levels right there's
the actual purchasing experience but
then there's also the experience of
using the products it depends on types
of products that you have like a jacket
might not have a huge time delay in
terms of using it if you sold custom
tailored stuff then delivering it faster
or finding a way to operationalize that
more quickly would be very real value
right right so there's the purchasing
process and then there's also the like
the wearing it process all right and
like unboxing and actually having them
experience again the dream outcome right
now finally of these four variables we
have effort and sacrifice and so the
purchasing decision here amazon has one
click purchases with everything on file
save so you can make a purchasing
decision in a split second right and so
that's why the rise of products like
bolt and shop pay are all things that
have decreased the effort and sacrifice
and a lot of ecommerce stores uh have
been able to use this to their advantage
and make more sales right and that's
because in a real way things would
become more valuable so it increased the
likely that people are going to buy all
right but let's look at the other
ratchets that i said these are inside of
the book are enhancers of value they do
even more to increase the value equation
in your favor so that you can buy sorry
you can sell more stuffs okay so let's
look at amazon for example what do they
have under virtually every single item
how many they have left in stock is
their way of showing scarcity only two
left only six left only 17 left and then
they have it by size right so that they
can show scarcity at every single level
huh what does that do it drives
conversions people want to buy all right
are you guys are you guys tracking with
me does this feel like it applies to
e-commerce let's keep going urgency what
else does amazon do they have lightning
deals right when you do a limited drop a
limited edition drop of a t-shirt
there's only 100 printed and we drop
them on friday and first come first
serve what does that do it gives
scarcity and because you were giving a
ti there's a time component it adds
urgency now to really add urgency we'd
say we're only selling these for an hour
um but hopefully the point drives home
all right but a lightning deal for
example where they said we're only
giving this price for for 60 minutes
that is absolutely urgency all right
saying how many you have left is
absolutely scarcity are you guys
tracking with this all right cool now
guarantees so what do we do here well
amazon took this one step further not
only did they already have a money back
guarantee right because it's
satisfaction you don't have to do
anything you just send it back and they
made it easy to return stuff what they
did now is try before you buy right so
they have seven day layaway so you can
buy the thing and they charge you seven
days later you can literally try the
thing on and not even have to get billed
on the card right why'd they do that
it's a version of a guarantee why
because what we're doing is we're
decreasing the risk of someone
purchasing right that's what we're doing
here we're decreasing the like we're
decreasing the likelihood that they have
a poor experience which as an inverse
increases the likelihood that they do
have a positive experience if they
choose to purchase so it's like if i'm
trying it on before i buy it then i'll
be very darn sure that if i like it i
might perceive likely to achieve
achieving the outcome after i'm wearing
it is very very high that's why they did
it right this is an implied guarantee
it's a version of guaranteed so they
technically have two guarantees they
have one which is the money back
guarantee which has now become almost
table stakes for physical products but
on top of that they added in a try
before you buy all right now bonuses all
right some of these ones will include
bonuses like the training that i said
for for levi's like little videos on how
you can tips and tricks on how you can
use this thing right if you have a
widget that's like at home health
kitchen stuff having videos on how they
can actually use the thing in better
ways is huge if you have a supplement
business for example telling people how
to take the products and the best things
to combine it with and what time of day
and how they can make sure they don't
forget it and blah blah those are all
things that can be bonuses that can be
perceived benefits of doing the thing
right and all of this stuff goes back to
these variables okay in increasing value
and increasing the likelihood somebody
wants to buy all right and then finally
naming it in a way that i think it will
be cool if i said my dream outcome was
that i wanted a warm jacket then
probably having warm or hot or fire or
flames or oven right in the name might
be something that would increase my
likelihood that i'm thinking this is
going to be something that will help me
experience my dream outcome right okay
now on the flip side if i wanted just
something that was fashionable and light
then it might be a light fashion jacket
right and so it's telling me the dream
outcome so we have to be explicit in
what we're doing and i'll also bet you
right that you'll have different avatars
that will be attracted to different
things or maybe you same avatar but
they're they're solving different needs
so the question is what job is are we
trying to do what's the job to be done
and then everything else is going to
fall down from there now amazon
specifically people name it based on the
things that people search for right
which makes sense because why would they
do that because it's exactly what i was
looking for by naming it properly and so
my hope here is that uh this video at
least gives you a little bit of a
cursory overview of the things that you
can do within an e-commerce or physical
products business to apply the 100 offer
framework to make your stuff more
buyable so that people increase in
higher amounts at higher percentages and
they do so willing to pay higher prices
because you have checked all these boxes
off and the competitors that you have
might even have the same product as you
but they haven't increased the perceived
likative achievement they haven't shown
how demonstrated how they can use the
product they don't have guarantees they
don't have tribe before you buy it takes
two weeks to get there and the
purchasing process is a pain in the ass
they have to make an entire profile they
have to do all the stuff right and they
find out that there is no scarcity so as
far as they're concerned they can buy
this whenever so they can come back next
week if they feel like it right and
there's no urgency or time timeline
where they do it because maybe maybe
this is seasonal for for you but for
them it's year-round so again they can
take even more time to make the decision
right and then in terms of bonuses yours
comes with all these different trainings
and things like that they can and how to
use the product and how to use it in
different ways and even how to use it
for different avatars to solve different
problems right because people are going
to experience different problems that
they're using they're hiring your
product to solve right and then of
course your competitors calls it jacket
and you say like fashion jacket and all
of a sudden the person says you know
what i think this is exactly what i need
and i'm going to buy right that is how
you can apply the 100 offers framework
including the value equation and the
other things that i talk about enhancing
value from the book to a physical
product business all right so mostly
nation i love you guys keep being
awesome and i'll catch you guys in the
next vid bye mozzie nation if you
enjoyed that video smash the subscribe
button and hit the little notification
bell the reason for that is because i
don't actually have a cadence when i
make these videos so if you want to make
sure you don't miss the next one that
comes out go subscribe notify and i'll
see you the next one bye